So I'm focusing on the Imperial Hotel, which
was first commissioned in 1915.
It went through a whole design process in
Taliesin and then built on site completed
around 1922-23 just when the September 1st,
1923 earthquake hit in Tokyo, famously surviving
that and having a 45-year existence being
before and after World War 2 but then demolished
in 1967 in November just before the 1970 Osaka
Expo and the rise of high-rise buildings.
So one of the great finds is this book from
1924 that was published just after it opened
after the earthquake in Japan that I'd never
seen before, this book has been fantastic
in bringing it back to life.
What's amazing about it when you open it up,
you see the title in Japanese but then you
see Frank Lloyd Wright in English.
Wright is misspelled, W-r-g-h-i-t.
As you flip through the pages, you see the
plans, which are actually very different from
what was first designed in Taliesin, and then
you get a whole glimpse of the hotel from
the street, the rooms, and in the detailed
plan it shows you, actually with hand notations
that I believe were Wright's, where the photographs
were taken.
Also, with the photographs, as we think about
this notion of reframing, we can literally
see that through photographs that are cropped,
framed to be very vertical, very horizontal,
and show the particular vision of Frank Lloyd
Wright’s.
And one, in particular, that I was very inspired
by, is one looking from the inside to the
garden covered with snow and it's framed in
a way that is reminiscent of a Hiroshige print.
That says The Jewel of the Orient and talks
about it being a blending of both East and
West or actually that it is neither of the
East nor of the West but that perfect blending
and so how that works, this is also part of
the reframing, that it's not simply one or
the other, we see it in that dynamic process
and all the ideas that shaped it then also
as it is brought to life for the guests who
go there.
Neither is East nor West becomes very important,
I think, in understanding the greatness of
the Wright design and not putting him into
a category but really understanding this international
experience that you would have had at the
hotel.
This incredible experience of entering into
a world shaped by the use of materials, the
oya stone, a whole world of furniture, china,
rugs that are ordered and composed but in
a very dynamic way.